it's Disney's runaway hit frozen just a
little over a year since it came out and
people still won't shut up about this
movie it's a cultural phenomenon I have
not seen an anime film from Disney get
this much attention since Lion King
everybody's still singing the songs
everybody's still quoting the lines
everybody's still selling the
merchandise it's just a monster like
probably most of you I kind of agree
it's all over the place and most likely
overplayed but I'm not gonna lie I'm one
of those people that loves it just as
much as anyone else the story is about
two princesses named Elsa and Anna Elsa
has a curse where she can control the
cold she can make it snow shoot ice beam
create snowmen all sorts of craziness
but one night as a little kid she
accidentally almost kills her sister her
mom and dad take them to a group of Rock
gnomes who say that they can save her
but they had to keep the power a secret
so they erase Anna's memory and decide
that it's best to keep them as far apart
as possible in hopes that our power
won't hurt her anymore
years go by and after the parents
tragically die the two of them grow up
into polar opposites Elsa not
surprisingly is an awkward introvert and
Anna is a social butterfly ready to open
up to anybody on the day of Elsa's
coronation as Queen Anna accidentally
reveals Elsa's powers to everybody
causing Elsa to run away and leave the
entire kingdom in ice so it's up to Anna
to find her sister and convince her to
come back and stop all this winter along
her way she comes across a climber named
Kristoff a magical snowman named Olaf
and all sorts of crazy adventures trying
to not only save the kingdom but her
sister as well there are so many things
to talk about with this movie it's hard
to know where to even start probably the
thing I'm impressed with most is their
ability to break certain cliches while
still holding true to others that make
Disney so popular but they do it in a
way that's not so obvious it feels very
natural in the way they set up these
characters I thought back to films like
Enchanted where they just hammered the
lesson in that they're going against
these Disney cliches and here it just
felt like it was part of a story they
would tell even if it wasn't Disney
related because it ties into what's
going on nowadays and will continue to
happen in the future for example there
is still a romance that blooms in only a
few days but they also mark the
fact that she's going to marry somebody
that she just met which of course is a
big criticism the female leads in the
past but this also makes sense for the
character she has been shut away for so
long that she would just give herself to
anybody it's a new experience and she
would be excited but this movie is
showing the dangers of it in fact
originally I was kind of against the
idea that there was sort of a
last-minute villain thrown in but
without giving away too much this once
again shows a really good lesson the
surprise reveal shows the danger of
being too trusting to anybody which is
not only a good lesson for kids but a
really good lesson for kids nowadays
with the social media and everybody on
it so often both Anna and Elsa are
perfect extremes to learn something from
Elsa is an introvert who wants to stay
away from people much like how some
people can just be glued to their
computers and phones and not go outside
that much people need to know how to
socially interact if they're going to
survive but Anna has the opposite
problem if you reveal too much about
yourself and will just give your heart
to anybody again like a lot of people on
the social media do there can be a
downside to that as well
the characters are also likable not only
do we have two princesses in this but
one of them moves on the Queen isn't
evil is actually really respectable and
smart and the other isn't so dainty and
basic she's really really funny they
don't mind if they make her a little bit
of a ditz you're there because it's
totally explained why the situation
totally backs up why she would be this
way but at the same time she's very
likable you love her passion and there
is something so nice knowing that the
majority of the humor that comes from
this movie comes from the main
characters and not all just in comic
relief the main characters can be funny
and goofy well that's it
even the obvious comic relief they do
bring in isn't really that bad
I don't think Olaf is a hilarious
character but I got a laugh out of him
once in a while and he wasn't annoying
where most Disney sidekicks get a lot of
their humor from yelling and being loud
this one actually whispers a lot of his
jokes I haven't really seen that in a
Disney fairy tale and it's actually
really effective and funny the music
what can I say you're all still humming
these tunes let it go you want to build
a snowman for the first time in forever
I remember when I was first talking
about these songwriters in the Winnie
the Pooh movie and I said I so want them
to go onto something cuz these are such
great songs holy did they get
rewarded for their talents people are
still singing these songs they're
releasing it in theaters with little
sing-along lyrics at the bottom it's
just insane how popular they are and
what I love about too is that the songs
helped the movie and tell the story
that's what the Disney musicals did they
didn't just say let's get a pop star
like Elton John to write five songs that
honestly if you took them out you
wouldn't miss that much in terms of
story or someone like Phil Collins who
just sort of sings in the background
that you could have just replaced with
orchestral music and nothing would
change whatsoever
these are songs that actually explain
what the characters are going through
and moved the story forward and they're
done fantastically I know I did in this
Dowager Craig video criticizing the fact
that it's played all over the place and
yeah it is I'm not gonna act like it
isn't we are over playing it I'm sure
it's driving most people insane but the
sad truth is I'm one of those obnoxious
people who plays it over and over that
doesn't mean I won't make fun of it but
yeah I'm one of those morons who does it
but to be fair I only listen to it in my
car without any kids to play it for
actually sits at me really pathetic but
I don't care I love the music that much
the film is also gorgeous looking I
could almost see people whipping this
out around every Christmas look at the
way they shoot winter look at the colors
look at the angles look at the
landscapes I could get lost in this
winter I want to live in this winter
which I know I kind of do but this one
looks nicer if I did have a problem with
anything I would say that the back story
is really rushed I know for some people
those elements can really turn them off
as I've heard their major criticisms
like why they did do this to the two
little girls and shouldn't have grown
them up this way and so on so forth
and I get it it is kind of a plot hole
and in the development of our main
characters that sort of causes all this
but personally I give it a little bit of
a leeway because I say that's kind of a
fairy tale element sort of like how is
Luke Skywalker firing one torpedo gonna
blow up the entire Death Star or how is
it the Joker took down the batplane with
one bullet from his gun it's one of
those creative liberties that for me is
worth going through to get to the best
parts of the story with that said frozen
is one of my
ten favorite Disney films hell maybe
even top five it brought me right back
into that feeling that I was seeing
something big and grand and Disney and
on top of that it was a fairy tale
when's the last time you saw a
traditional fairy tale take the world by
storm I don't mean something like tangle
that was a hit or once upon a time
that's doing well I mean like take over
the world it's been a while but it's
great to see again and yeah like I said
it is probably being exploited a little
too much and all over the place but hell
I much rather have kids and adults
rewatch this than say transformers a
twilight this one has so much more
creativity and intelligence to it and
music and visuals and characters and
just I'm just gushing all over it again
it's one of the few films I can just
proclaim as an instant classic a film
you can guarantee years from now
millions of people are still going to be
watching and sharing with their kids
hell with other adults I'd say go check
it out but who the hell hasn't just go
watch it again I know I'm going to and
have a hell of a lot of fun doing it
you